hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar rethinking the
timeline required for Quality by Design
studies in protein process development I
am Brenda Kelly Kim labyrinth I'll be
moderating today's session today's
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's sponsored by perkin-elmer
PerkinElmer instrumentation helps to
advance biotherapeutics research by
automating small-scale protein
purification and protein
characterization to learn more please
visit us at www.piofl.com I'd to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window please click
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of slide window if you experience
any technical problems seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the
support button found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left I will now
present today's speakers Lou fabry is a
senior member of the CSL research staff
heading up the protein chemistry
purification group he leads the
high-throughput purification of protein
and macromolecular assessment of
proteins for research based studies in
CSL limited Lou will be followed by bill
clarity a bioprocess scientist with
Merrimack pharmaceuticals within the
process development group where he is
charged developing methods and
characterizing molecules as well as
supporting process to
development and manufacturing prior to
this role you work for eight years first
at wyatts and Pfizer contributing to
analytical development efforts across
their pipeline bill is a WPI grad the
substantial experience and assay
development across multiple research
areas and validation GMP environment
I'll now turn it over to lose to begin
to the presentation
hi it's a loose I agree here from
yourself and my talk today is that based
on protein purification and the high
throughput protein production in the
research based industry settings so by
way of introduction what I would like to
speak about is just a little bit about
their cell and who we are given that
we're here in Australia and then
specifically about what the research
group does and then from there sort of
going to what we do within the protein
purification group now one of the things
I'll talk about is the fact that we
produce quite a lot of proteins within
the research group and one of the key
tools for us to be able to do that is to
be able to achieve the throughput and we
did this array of multi-dimensional
chromatography traditionally with these
technologies such as the FDA Express but
more recently what we've been able to do
is miniaturize purification process and
utilized liquid handling to see such as
for Janice to produce the purification
that we need in a Hydra commode now once
we've been able to do that one of the
things we need to do make sure we can
take full of is producing utilizing the
janitor of multi-dimensional
chromatography and ultimately I'll just
make the concluding remarks about have a
successful we've been in producing a
purification system utilizing liquid
handling system magenta so psl is a
global specialty biopharmaceutical
company and we last year had 25 billion
dollars in sales in plasma products and
predominantly these days apprentice such
as argument and uniform with the manager
we are now opposes second Rogers up flu
vaccine companies in the world and CFL
employed 16,000 employees will arrive in
as many is going to come
treat and some of those are expensive
it's that others are actually
significant manufacturing practices are
that it's a special group last year CSL
thanks 460 million dollars in R&D
investment alone so there's quite a huge
focus on our own game and develop a new
product if in CSL more recently we've
introduced to recombinant protein based
therapeutics a Delvian and that Scylla
and these are both recombinant protein
based therapeutics providing treatment
in both hemophilia A and hematuria both
a day well more long term some of the
types of proteins of CSL is also trying
to develop as well and additional other
coagulation therapy recombinant proteins
are recombinant antibodies and there's
quite a lot of work in our pipeline to
develop seeing as potential need
therapeutics for quite a few different
therapies so in terms of one of the
purposes of the research group we
predominantly try to discover league
protein candidate and then move those
through the discovery quad lines into
developing them as a drug candidate and
then consequently are dealing moving
these things through clinical trials and
into into being a pharmaceutical
products in such a competitive market
being able to do this fast efficiently
and effectively is really importantly
important key in terms of developing
therapeutics and within research
arranged to identify key protein very
early on look at the ability of having
food can be manufactured and focused on
generating these elite proteins
typically we're also working with very
small amounts of protein and we need to
do this so that we can produce a large
quantity of protein once selected the
protein other growth lead optimization
and ultimately solar cell line
development within the research group
before moving on to product development
and then ultimately on to manufacturing
so ideally what we try to do within the
research group he's actually not only
that I've defined as the efficacy of the
lead candidate but also powerful
transition through the formulation and
the purification steps that will be
coming coming on board in the different
processes so we produce quite a lot of
proteins and using this is essentially
the basis of my talk you is looking at
the numbers of proteins that we produce
for Leo anybody's watching and how we
are able to handle that sort of the
mouth so typically for example last year
we produced and have those two products
we use approximately about 1,500
proteins annually and this could be as
little as an overgrown quantities of
protein all the way through to gram
protein requirements for things like
preclinical tops any animal studies that
we do as well as we're also the esso
development we own stages of the
discovery process we also generate
material for reference shock as well as
feeding to equally poor cell line
development so ultimately for us two
types of selection processes that we
have the key consideration for
appointing you what the affinity of the
protein might be and identifying that in
terms of a selection process is critical
and also then looking at the efficacy of
the mountain material from the proof of
concept study in animal studies now
these two things are the primary
selection two products
area for pelicula equality candidate but
what we've introduced as really as has
many other industry company is the
concept of manufacturability and so I
dealing what that means for us can we
produce a clean product as other
research space can we look at how
reproducible encoding to do is it
consistently producing material with our
ideal modifications or ideally no
modifications and in terms of is it
stable at a molecular level so do we see
occupation for example do we do look at
any other post translational
modifications and if we do have these
things and we will consider them and
part of the selection criteria equally
looking at whether protein aggregates is
critical as well as whether we can
formulate the material in button that
would be typical during the downstream
processes so how do we achieve this
throughput that's right one of the key
proteins that we work with Suzanne so
keep a physically workish give
multi-dimensional chromatography given
that we do essentially purification with
the group utilizing multi-dimensional
chromatography is important from being
able to achieve the throughput that we
require the multi-dimensional
chromatography of course is the
separation of molecules through multiple
steps and not multiple stationary phases
sequentially to increase the separation
performance of the purification and for
us automated multidimensional
chromatography made utilizing
multidimensional chromatography but in
doing that with an instrument
independent of the user so typically
what happens is that the aleutian is one
protein during the first gradually fade
we'll be looking into a hobby route that
ultimately be introduced and in turn
into the second column and the loop
itself is an interface between the two
different places chromatography now in
terms of doing this and traditionally as
I said before we eat a live human such
as yet to experience the crisis
chromatography that I'm talking about I
think like fake a first step of affinity
purification and then subsequently salty
North products we journey to an
appropriate butter for us each of the
individual instrument is capable of
running for proteins and any one stage
and at a time this particular class we
have six of these particular units in
our group and that meant for example the
we were able to produce 24 handfuls per
day assuming that you would join your
energy and decently however if you do
inside excluding what that meant was
actually for protein six proteins today
which was equivalent to the sea creature
months that we have so ideally this room
could be is 70 proteins clinic or 100
samples all the way through or middle is
about 20 proteins too late so obviously
one needs to look at other processes for
being able to maximize their troop
however one of the good things about
this instrument that we also identified
was that there's a fairly good
correlation between what we would expect
as a theoretical recovery of each of in
terms of what we see so them that the
amount loaded so for example for as
little as two milligrams of protein the
overall observed Republic is around
eighty five percent on two stages of
chromatography and when you're using as
less as little as portaak milligram this
level goes down to about happiness on
cutting classes and recovery typically
the
with this instrument for physics we
below quantified milligrams the just the
law of diminishing returns would mainly
you learn for mostly protein so ideally
looking for an additional instrument is
critical and also looking at being able
to do more than just 20 to 100 samples
Kuwait was pretty pretty important one
of the things that we looked into with
utilizing the janet as we instrument of
choice and so here what I've done in
slides put up the extra method for
purification you can see what we do here
is we produce transient salon media and
then we apply that to an affinity
protein and purification in the math
lecture and then by a series of washes
we then allude that material and then
from the Aleutian it goes on to our
defaulting or projects cruises petition
itself goes undergo school cleaning in
place before a new sample is introduced
onto the column and hence the process
continues with the Janus we can do the
same thing but obviously in a much
smaller scale and utilizing columns such
as the at home we were able to have a
96-well plate array and the introduction
of a new shovel arm on the Janus allows
us to move between racks and doing
washes and then subsequent solutions so
ideally we can utilize it as they
apologize type extraction actually I
generate a purification the fractions
then of course they're losing to a
96-well plate then can be taken on for
subsequent purification so that could be
for example defaulting or it could be
projects cruising on a different
instrument one of the things we click is
very early on with looking at what the
dynamic binding capacity of the column
on oxygen policy at all columns would be
on the Janus as compared to reactor
and then we slide what you can see sort
of the resident I'm then technically
beginner and then also to reactor you
can see there's a significant overlap
and correlation from the three areas
that they overlap for the 25 minutes
second residence time and people is a
very close agreement in a dynamic
binding capacity and this is because all
other parameters are capable of being
kept constant so things like the
respective load and the linear flow
velocity means tenses one screen equal
why we Janice isn't shown at the higher
concentration is course of the fact that
it would be impractical practical to
load as much longer residence time for
the for the year for the genesis so
looking at the Janus platform
essentially we do affinity purification
and then going on to for exclusion or
dissolving the robo columns themselves
coming out of that hole are shown your
bottom lip and try to describe and you
can see at this point and some of these
some of the shower drain into the dry
bones and one of the the critical
features of this colony that it hasn't
only rather only at the top of the
column that causes the seal on on the
very spend arms as they go into the the
needles as they go into the column and
their corner feel that as a pneumatic
drive of the sample going through pushes
the liquid through the column so
essentially operates like Collinwood on
a hplc and actually is able to
accurately deliver volleys and on the
right-hand side we see how big these
conv and typically we have something
like about a hundred microliters of
reading within these columns and the
beauty is the
the size of these columns he said with a
hundred microliters and a dynamic on
capacity is typically about 30
milligrams and milk that means for a
hundred lucky literacy you could
probably put as much as the battery in
your grams of protein and that's
recoverable if if you are able to put it
within the low groaning required from
Jana and then subsequent to the actual
purification the fate of the elution
coming off East enemy column events
either default image and the bottom part
of the slide and what we utilize is a
96-well defaulting array plate column
consumes of 96 columns with one military
sausage or than 92 and it's a company
called BNP that these could be purchased
from and the maximum loading onto these
columns of three hundred microliters but
ideally the elution completely coming
off the road back on and then be applied
directly onto these columns and
dissolved in in once said if so the
question is required then you can also
just packing material onto to something
like an agilent system with an
appropriate content so that you can then
fractionated directly off that and we
utilize Palkia calling for the
autosampler as well as for the for the
fractionation device to make sure that
to deal with the throughput that we
require and typically what this means is
that we can get through at least 200
sample on a size exclusion and as many
is about 500 samples per week if we
actually need to go talk to my Lords out
of that triple subsequent to the
defaulting for the quality exclusion
there are many other instruments that we
utilize on the jet are coming off the
Janus to also deal with the throughput
of providing the energy
in our own you have to do sighs
inclusion that we have capabilities of
looking at multi angle right scattering
sds-page on the GX to as well as protein
conversation quantitation on the on the
job then some examples with our on the
caliper gx2 instrument and you can see
this is 45 sample of different antibody
runs in a single run which for us is
providing quite a lot of information on
the purity and the quality of material
that's coming off our Jana fisherman
likewise the drop sense is a tree
microliter nano UV that is capable of
generating pruning quantitation in an
unfixed well a race on that and the
beauty and instantly because the place I
was quite small it has a linearity up to
about 30 absorption units so therefore a
lot of samples this means is no dilution
required which allows you to be a lot
more accurately no UV quantitation
determination and finally in terms of
the other analytics that we can do you
describe exclusion analysis releases
that quite a few proteins run on on
overlaid onto the ranch exclusion to
showing that we can run it means about
500 proteins weekly Artemis column but
having done men we recently identified
that we can lead to Janet for
multi-agent Martin should very
multi-dimensional chromatography and one
of the one of the things that the guys
in my group spent doing and the last
year or so was to really optimize secure
vacation so we can use it at the
purification platform and punishment and
group is quite instrumental in doing
this for many of the other members in
the group as well as also Michael a
broken person Alma who originally came
up with the script that we use for the
purification and increases being
recently published in the Journal of
chromatography for those who would be
interested in having a look at this
paper so again the purification is that
agenus utilizing agenus with a transient
cellulite condition may yield typically
about the former load and this can be as
little as 50 micrograms or a half a
milligram all the way through without
three milligrams of protein it's applied
to the map collect on the road open 100
microliters there's a wash as well as
evolution process and then the
subsequent our desalting or if I between
as well as been for cleaning in places
and when we look at the test protein
such as looking for grand haven to clear
human unicorn or polyclonal in globulin
to derive you can see that for the
amount loaded on the left-hand panel
verse and cream and recovered which is
the open circles there's a fairly good
correlation with the material coming of
the probe protein a so we're getting
quite a neat recovery and we're seeing
the final yield which is the clothes con
drops down a little bit of course
because the the way the trapping occurs
on the default and calm but for Carlos
in less than 2 million times retrieving
as much as bad eighty-two percent
repetitive yield or recovery coming off
at con compared to that cp8 and for
higher loads and you can see this is
because that we're starting to see
material coming out or we're going to
reach the capacity they column and
material coming out in your breakthrough
p Please Please
by the open triangle one of the other
things that we tested on these columns
very early on with what the what the
potential cross-contamination was other
in the JC our contamination take the
Jacqueline where contamination or
subsequent run contamination and what
you can see we exclude the saturated
concrete formula grants the material
then subsequent rounds with PDF
essentially don't identify any carrier
protein and so this is really important
when you're considering utilizing these
things as a platform / typically what we
have identified that becomes computer
Farquaad in a linear fashion up to that
you're my heart milligrams of protein
and obviously to make more and get more
recovered however the recovery won't be
as good as at the lower concentrations
in tempe to finish the cupboard we would
look at real life samples was applied as
much as 200 antibodies on to the Janus
me and what you can see there is that
there is a direct relationship between
Ian downloaded the amount recovered and
foremost protein sewing things they tend
to fall in these patterns and when you
look at the speed the speed which is
quite easy to produce a hundred samples
in an eight-hour appearing and that this
material then can go on to defaulting
and so typically one need much is about
point 25 milligrams of protein in a milk
for that for milk of material or one
milligram of material can be loaded onto
the cone balloon to be education and
this correlates well can you turn to the
relationship with an amplitude versus
are recovered material on the Janice and
so looking at the Janus is an example of
400 antibodies to fight on the actor and
[Music]
and basically on a two-step protein a
going on consulting or whether the
throughput is a lot slower one can see
this feeling better after a good pass
linear relationship are in the low
probably of course of the actors that be
through putting the rock for now I'll
just jump one month slides killer and
what we also looked at is that some of
the proteins in terms of the 200 that we
loaded onto the these columns not we're
not recovered in levels that we would
have expected but they're sort of run
very very far from ideal and when we
look at the samples that are darkened in
this case 1327 and the quasi on supplies
including it's interesting to notice for
example whether you really call recovery
from illegal material really bad
behaviour ideal proteins and so ideally
what this suggesting that this is one
can even use expression versus recovery
as though sort of a predictor of power
around will perform and if you couple
that with the size region then one can
see whether these antibodies would be in
the being used to take on any further so
one of the key reasons that the
purification on the janet has also
become very capable is that they have
been advancing in transient expression
that allows for us to be able to reach
the quantities required during the load
process so for example from 250
different on a coil antibody expression
the average expression level is about a
half
grant / Mel so on a formula gram sorry
I'm a formula right this is equivalent
on average to about 2 milligrams loaded
which is a really good concentration to
be loading onto these rubber columns and
when we look at how many proteins are
less than the point 5 milligrams which
ideally would need to be minimum amount
loaded on calm we only see about four
points four percent of these proteins
samples at that threshold so ideally
what that means is about 80
three-point-six percent of these
proteins would be loaded at greater than
one milligram an early 4.4% of these
would not be applied to the image
analysis for the expiation really good
system and dovetails very well with the
chance for purification and this is
about contrast to our previous
expression systems such as the Freestyle
any human embryonic kidney set one where
for example on 400 clone on average we
with being about point our 50 micrograms
the milk flow ting so ideally what that
means is only about point seven five
things we find could be processed by
this method and essentially 99% of them
could not utilize the magenta so having
an expression system is capable of
producing grades and point 25 milligrams
to know what prank is really critical to
having the right study material
concentration to be able to load onto
these column so in conclusion or some of
the concluding remarks even the CFL
group produces about 1500 points
annually to support the research group
the Janus is used for a large number of
these purifications so that we can do
see antonis purification many proteins
on the aerobic on and be able to put
these inappropriate buses for other
implications or violently assaulting
ography affinity revenues that we use I
think got a protein a protein g we
neglect and the concentration would have
to be greater than 125 milligrams per ml
and typically formula load can be loaded
onto the column up to four mil we've
seen columns at last and the final note
that I've gosselin saying that the scene
Rover columns can it clean and recycle
of runs on the Unruh Jenna but typically
we were more comfortable with using
these columns at about 15 cycles and
then introducing a an analysis of the
columns before we then do additional run
on them and this is because they're
there has been observed deterioration
the only and sometimes these columns and
fail after about 15 cycles so any using
for 15 cycles won't quite get quite as
quite a few runs batted in columns and
and by testing the month additionally
you can get quite a few and identify the
ones that are going to be a problem um
and you send through additional cycles
as well so the last thing I have to do
to thank the guys in my group Peter [ __ ]
and the other guys in the group as well
as well as within molecular biology food
can be a charge and I think we did quite
a lot of the expression work control
chamber and and Georgina came in with
inquest normal between people and repair
leon help to actually get a liquid
handling system as a purification system
in Okinawa with my collector and Jeremy
Lambert and just thank you everyone for
being here and listen kid
all right good morning everybody my name
is Bill flirty and i'll be doing me the
second portion of the stock kettle my
presentation is the assessment of
targeting arm pegylation in a complex
with its own therapeutic we're going to
examine using the caliper GX 2 c-e SDS
system as a tool to positively identify
the pegylated conjugate that functions
as a targeting arm for our encapsulated
chemotherapy lipids own drug product
this product is known as mmm 302 it's
currently in Phase two it specifically
targets human epidermal growth factor
receptor 20 it's known as r2 and our
hope is that it provides patients that
have are even treated with other drug
regimens a new and effective treatment
the bulk of my discussion will be
focused on the scfv protein portion of
the molecule that talk to specifically
targets or two and how we can access the
chronicle assess the product quality of
this protein 12 the start of B bulk drug
substance a quick note about Merrimack
who we are and what we do we are a
company located in cambridge
massachusetts all of our pipeline
projects are going after oncology
targets or a group of scientists and
engineers dedicated to helping the world
treat and ultimately cure and eradicate
cancer your systems biology model that
looks to define and treat the cause of
disease so we do a lot of molecular
modeling to find specific targets for
our drugs so the GX why we're using it
and what it is so we have the GX 2
system the blue boxes as it's known
colloquium around the company why do we
use it it's very easy to use for even
for unfamiliar
at this you can provide a plate for
testing simply having to dilute samples
it's high throughput um easy to run day
of experiments and provide real-time
data is necessary it's like running up
to a chels at once much faster to
completion and much easier to analyze
the data as well as the consistency
being very very very consistent good
chip-to-chip reproducibility and very
low variability so the molecule mmm 302
it's a me natal episomal construct that
we use here at Merrimack it's made of
three primary portions the top portion
is the protein to incorporate the
protein into the Olympus ohm we
conjugate it with a peg molecule and it
is a number of those are incorporated on
to the final drug substance which is the
encapsulated chemotherapy nano episome
drug product so the important portion
and the portion that we're going to
specifically look at today is ensuring
that we have the tag linker on our
protein so that it can be inserted
correctly into the lipid zone so our
purification process for this molecule
is obviously much more complicated than
a standard mad so here's an
oversimplified version of the
purification it's all the way through
first column second column and you fgf2
we defined your initial protein
purification the scfv is the protein
it's then prepared for conjugation
conjugated with a peg molecule it goes
through another set of purification
steps and is incorporated into the
liposome so
so we want to devise a strategy where we
can have one simple method to help
identify and quanti the status of our
protein throughout the purification
conjugation and live is owned
corporation it's three individual steps
across a significant significantly
longer purification and lipid on
construction train then would be done
typically for a map so here is the an
electropherogram directly from the GX
I'll walk through this this has both the
scfv protein portion and the kanji
apportioned shown same same
electropherograms so on the y-axis you
have your fluorescence and on your ex
you have the sides the scfv is
approximately twenty-seven twenty-eight
kilo dalton protein it exists as both
the monomer and I American see both
species there d sav conjugate is shown
in brown and red in this trace the two
samples here are distinct lack of kanji
that we've produced we know that there
are some differences in a tag elation
pattern the conjugates I want to want to
show if the GX can identify a mono
pegylated to a single tag edition
conjugate compared to an over pegylated
in ecology of material so the TKE at 29
and 30 kilotons is the model pegylated
conjugate ticket 36 is an over pegleg
kanji it and the peak eps 41 is also an
older pegylated kanji so the GX is able
to detect three distinct species is
protein congee at mixture within three
kilo dalton chokes the static confirms
we've suspected from sds-page
separations the gels are partially able
to resolve the species but smearing and
low concentration coupled with lack of
quantitation on the gel in provide with
the most definitive data to allow us to
demonstrate an understanding the
conjugation state and the status of
material to move forward and fulfill
incorporation so this is a significant
increase in sensitivity we can
positively identify the conjugate and
multiple conjugate species
and we have an ability to understand the
overt I galatian rate of our conjugate
which can change from lock to lock here
is another electropherogram from the GX
this is a football full view so we want
to look again at what this tells us so
it actually tells us a great deal of
information we can see the status of the
single chain the scfv as both a monomer
in a dimer we can see the mono pegylated
conjugate and they over calculated
conjugate we can see that there's no
fraction of the protein that exists and
we're seeing a definitive size
separation across a very small change in
size this is the same samples under a
reducing condition to prove that we
aren't just seeing Ashley artifacts we
ran under reducing conditions as well
the only changes that we are that we see
here is a reduction of our anticipated
reduction of a reducible dimer of the
single chain fvfv so we can further
confirm that the kanji species that we
are seeing are in fact the conjugates
that we are claiming to be so now that
we have an understanding of our ability
to see the conjugate can we quantitate
the species that are there looking at
the pegylated conjugated various
constant diluted concentrations we're
able to understand we're able to see if
we can quantitate the conjugates so our
conjugate linearity from our starting
concentration down below our anticipated
concentration is it correlates fairly
well we know the final concentration of
our protein in North Zone drug product
and we were able to quantitate well
below that one
our biggest hurdle with the kanji at
standard curve is the percent of the old
regulated material present in each lot
in detail we know the amount will vary
slightly the curve here is using total
area all conjugate species observe the
total protein concentration should not
be impacted by presence of separately
distinction apology gate species but a
correlation should be done on different
Lots conjugate with high and low percent
over conjugated material to understand
the one-to-one correlation this may
prove to be a fully quantitative methods
for poking total protein and illiberal
incorporation simple it's very promising
and offers a significant increase in
quantitative understanding over our
typical sds-page methods now that I've
developed a method to observe
intentionally quantitate the contrary
material find a way to abstract it from
the liposome is imperative so we did
some initial detergent experiments to
dissociate the conjugate formalism
itself here are some substandard
detergent treatments all compatible with
the GX platform we have Triton bridge 35
and a few others all of these proves to
be I have too much background noise or
not sufficiently able to separate the
conjugate from the liposome so new ideas
need to be explored to understand oh if
we could simply see the conjugate once
they have been incorporated into the old
Azam drug product here's is a pretty
messy electropherogram this is power a
look at our all about drug components
and how they obscure our ability to see
our actual protein and how our take home
message here is the conjugate species
that we want to see is
scared by all of the other components of
the drug product what can we do to
understand to remove these other
components and see our protein of
interest so the typical GX method only
calls for a dilution so if we explore
the technique up front that allow us to
clear Olympic components in the
chemotherapy reagent that don't allow
the quantitative protein will we be able
then to see our protein of interest here
are two initial look at purifying away
the rigid and additional material so our
first was using a molecular lake
off-spin filter to remove small lipid
components and the chemotherapy and
concentrate a conjugate protein it would
give us a great signal and declare
acceleration contamination as it worked
unfortunately it was only able to
concentrate the chemotherapy and I was
not able to recover the protein of
interest a second method that we
attempted was an ethanol precipitation
and subsequent chillin at minus 80
Celsius so we had a significant bolus of
ethanol to separate this intercepted two
sample spin it healthy protein and
described supernatant hopefully only
reconstituting the protein in this prep
we froze the sample to encourage the
lipids to break apart and provide
additional stress to remove contaminants
or lipid portions of our proteins and
leaving our conjugate intact invisible
this preparation recovers protein we
still see significant signal from other
components I notice during this portion
that they lifted the pellet process was
not as optimal as we would like to see
so it's possible that we carried through
some of the lipid components and we're
not looking too early at our conjugate
material
here we see the final prep that we
undertook the the ethanol precipitation
and compared in fats in red and we're
comparing that against our initial no
prep lipids ohm drug product loaded
directly onto the plate so what we had
wanted to see was removal of all the
intermediate signal between what's here
is about eight and thirty kill adult so
what we were able to do is resolve and
clear the drug components that were
obscuring your view we do still see a
significant peak at about five seconds
flat kill Dalton's doxorubicin that is
coming through with our final drug
product but it is not obscuring our
ability to see our protein so this is
the final condition that we move forward
with fully able to resolve our conjugate
species away from the liposome and
extract it from the lipid zone here we
have the reference conjugate reference
material that we'd used for initial
quantitation just experiment compared
with a conjugate that is precipitated
from an actual representative product
what you can see in in blue is the
conjugate reference and what you can see
in red is the material we were able to
abstract from the middle of his own so
what this tells us is that we are able
to pull that conjugate out and recover
it quite well the conjugate reference
here is diluted to
any specific concentration that
concentration is approximately what we
would expect to see coming out of the
lip is owned and we are within five
percent we totally protein recovery by
total area of our anticipated
concentration here we have a look at
repeatability these are two separate
precipitation drug product
precipitations done on two consecutive
days and run on the same chip so what
we're able to see is that we are able to
completely resolve this protein on
multiple days on multiple preps and get
very very good very consistent recovery
from day to day an experiment to
experiment so we want to make sure that
we are are seeing what we what we think
we're seeing so we devised reverse-phase
hplc method to separate out the
conjugate the mono pegylated conjugate
as well as the over pegylated console
conjugate and here we have the mono peg
conjugate the single tag away to
conjugate and they over pegylated
ecology it so we confirm the presence of
both in the same material using an
orthogonal method and took this method
and put it on the front end of a mass
spec which allowed us to here's a some
mass spectra data that shows
specifically the presence of both model
and over pegylated conjugate species
using that regard phase hplc UV method
what this tells us is that everything
that we saw on the
GX is confirmed and we can use the GX as
a in process daily measurement tool as
opposed to having to run math data each
time we have a sample which
significantly increases our throughput
and allows us to provide real-time
answers to the group's so conclusions
the GX will be proposed as a commercial
law release methods for evaluating size
heterogeneity in the ecology we will be
able to report the unconjugated single
chain protein the mono pegylated
conjugate protein and the over pegylated
conjugate protein which is a significant
increase in our ability to see these
species over the traditional sds-page
methods the protein precipitation and
condition optimization enable analysis
of conjugate southsider today directly
from the nan ilysm they are able to
extract to be conjugate from the final
drug product and quantitate and fully
observe the protein has reported out the
data implies that the method is
repeatable in robust as a relevant want
a shin approach again we can report
multiple species and absolute
quantitation should be achieved with
some optimization the experiments are
ongoing that would be the ultimate goal
would be to fully absolutely quantitate
all the different species that were
pulling out of the drug product now with
that I just want to say thank you to my
team at merrimack also analytics
Department and the nano episomal
development team that I work with
closely during this process oh thank you
thank you both Lou and bill for bringing
us that informative presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
make your question simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green to a button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many questions as our time permits and
we do have our first question an
attendee asks i'm looking into equipment
for high-throughput HEK expressions
what's shaking speed do you use in your
incubators I've heard that you need a
very high shaking speed so I said I
that's more question I could you um ah
get off yep we are we're only doing for
a lot of this small scale expressions
very small volume and and from what I
understand the fairly standard method
that actually probably doesn't all those
speeds are high they're not excessively
hard I do know that they utilize tinkle
rodas and yeah and the actual and flasks
that they use of the five mil 24 10 mil
tube that they use being sort of
specifically designed to create very
deterioration and I'd be happy to put
you in contact with the molecular
expression guys could be happy to share
from the day oh I'm pretty sure we've
actually published some of that any one
of our early papers where we've taken
material and and looked at generating a
platform for a hard to put expression
and so so yeah so so I'm sorry I can
answer that means a lot of detail but
yeah that that's I don't think the
speaker physically hi okay we have
another question you change cell strain
to improve expression level
did you also look at the vector I'm
pretty sure that the victims they used
were the the manufacturing victims for
the for that particular XP so long for
the salon interest in a selected
Australian for high-throughput
expression and it just enables that
expression to go ahead having said that
when we actually generate larger
quantities and material we do codon
optimization as well as vector
optimization for for the purification so
that we can get the yields up but
typically look for example like in that
slide where i showed in 250 anybody's
that's a good path purification taking
CDRs out of anybody's and then just
going and putting it into our frame I
you know our format platform for
expression okay thank you another
question for you Luis can you elaborate
a bit on the upstream expression process
I'm not entirely sure what they would
like us to elaborate on to be honest
that question has a bit more detail
please okay I'm sure our attendee can
type in some more detail in the meantime
we'll move on to another question from
another attendee I saw mostly method
development details presented rather
than qbd approaches what was the
connection to cutie
is this directed more toward my
presentation I believe perhaps all right
yeah this did have more than that the
development aspect to it however I would
say that the throughput of GX lends
itself to the ability to run far more
samples in our detergent application and
all of our standard care development was
it increases the time was significantly
lesson through using the lab ship as
opposed to typical sds-page style
methods so it's not a true quality by
design approach but the throughput and
the data received enabled a lot more
lessons learned in the facial area time
ok and I'll see another college go ahead
I just a follow on from that bring your
I suppose in respect to my talk and the
early phase of discovery or research
identifying issue we part of how we can
assign this or the quality of tributes
and the design parameters that you
acquire in qbd so having some
understanding of what our proteins
behave at that early stage it's really
very you know the initial part of that a
QED approach and and I think that's
where we would have a role to play in
that of course it's not to be deeper say
that it's sort of starting to think
about what we need to do when we come to
that study I see okay we do have the
next question for bill I'm surprised
that the peg peaks are not broad is the
peg of a very defined side yes the peg
molecule is a uniform in size and it is
relatively small
so we are able to separate those rocks
if it's about three KD difference on
each for each peg added this is not peg
2000 or any of the large pegs but we do
know the size of this peg and it's and
we're able to see even one versus two on
the system okay great we have another
question what's the approximate
sensitivity of purity what percent scfv
/ pegylated species can you see we were
able to see down to approximately one
percent total protein in the various
different different species which is a
significant improvement over the SDS
page and the older bioanalyzer methods
well we wouldn't be able to detect these
species at such a low percentage okay
thank you I'm afraid that is all the
time we have now for questions today I
want to thank our audience for bringing
such a great bunch of information for
questions to our presenters bill or lose
you have any final comments for the
audience no just anger you to
participate year and follow me if
anyone's got any additional questions
beyond this tool from happy to answer
them to a later stage great i activate
my echo those sentiments thank you very
much thank you both for being here I
also do want to thank our sponsor
perkin-elmer from making this
presentation possible today if we didn't
get your question we will follow up via
email this webcast can be viewed on
demand through December 2016 lab roots
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time thank you for
participating today and goodbye